and Governor Younkin joins us now sir
how are you
great Sean thank
you okay I have been screaming this from
The Mountaintop almost every day
Republicans have to get over their
reluctance and resistance to voting
early voting by mail and where there is
legal ballot harvesting laws they have
got to match Democratic efforts what are
you doing in Virginia and what should we
be duplicating
yeah so first Sean you're exactly right
we have critical elections this year
it's the midterms in Virginia and uh so
our entire house and our entire Senate
is up we have a majority in our house I
want to get a majority in our Senate and
we got to get Republicans off the
sidelines and get them to vote early I'm
tired of going into elections down
thousands of votes on Election Day and
so we've launched
secureyourvotevirginia.com and we are
asking Republicans come to our website
uh sign up to get an absentee ballot
sign up to be on the permanent absentee
ballot list or just make a plan to vote
early but come vote we cannot sit on the
sidelines any longer you said it exactly
the rules are the rules so let's compete
and win we had a robust early voting
program in 2021 when Virginians hired me
and win some Sears and Jason miares on a
Statewide election and kind of shocked
the world and we're doubling down I'm
asking people to go to secure your
virginia.com make a plan to vote early
and let's win this thing all right so
what you're saying is right you go to
battle with the Army you have not the
one you wish you had this is the system
whether we like it or not but it's not
just being down thousands of votes in
some cases it's hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of votes on Election Day that
have to be made up now the Republican
National Committee they've started their
effort they're calling it Bank the vote
I applaud their effort there but they
have yet to that I have seen match the
ballot harvesting initiatives that
Democrats are using which allows them to
hide and not debate and not even
campaign or shake hands or kiss babies
or do town halls or or even percivals so
that's got to stop Republicans got to
match the Democratic effort in that
regard as well right
yeah so first of all we're still going
to campaign like crazy and kiss babies
and go to town halls and on top of that
we're going to compete to win the rules
of the rules we're going to play hard
and that's why this initiative is so
important it's a big collaboration from
the rslc from our state caucuses from my
pack in my office and we are going to
drive early voting absentee ballots and
we're not going to be behind on Election
Day these are critical elections for us
listen we've got a lot done in Virginia
when I came into office Sean Virginia
was 47th in the nation in job recovery
coming out of the pandemic now 18 months
later we're top five we're competing
we're winning but there are so many
frustrating things you know ours this
the Senate that's controlled by
democrats they block Common Sense bills
like allowing Virginians to decide what
kind of car we're going to drive as
opposed to currently they'd given the
right to California to dictate what cars
we're going to drive I want to penalize
dealers whose drugs kill victims with a
homicide felony they block that I want
to protect our children from social
media companies harvesting their data
they block that I want to lower taxes
further we're running a huge Surplus on
top of a four billion dollar tax cut
last year they're blocking that we have
to get our Senate back this is how we're
going to get it done we're going to
campaign like crazy we have great
candidates and we're going to secure
your votevirginia.com and vote early all
right I urge every Republican and every
state every governor and every state
that's Republican follow this initiative
and add the ballot harvesting if it's
allowed in your state legally thank you
sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else